One of the things I've been talking about
during the last year of Donald Trump's presidency
and during the campaign and during the transition
period and during Joe Biden's nascent presidency,
is that the Republican Party at this point
has stopped even pretending to be about policy
and values and is merely about performative
outrage, misplaced outrage, laughable outrage.
We're going to look at an example in a moment.
But I think this is an important sort of reset
to do.
And I know many of you might be thinking,
David, you know, the Republican Party hasn't
really been about policy for a very long time.
That's true.
But they used to pretend to be about policy
for a time.
The Republican Party really was about tax
cuts for the rich, cutting budgets by cutting
social programs, spreading, spreading the,
quote, spreading democracy through invasive
foreign policy around the world.
They tried passing bills to get these things
done eventually during the end of the Bush
era and into the Barack Obama presidency,
both terms, the Republican Party started to
become about policy in name only, but not
sincerely.
They went from really trying to do policy
to just talking about it, but not really caring
about policy.
You know, they'd claim to be about cutting
the deficit and reducing the debt and fiscal
responsibility, but not when George W. Bush
wanted to explode the deficit by going to
war with the wrong country.
And they refused to acknowledge when Barack
Obama did cut the deficit.
So they went from being about a few policies,
bad policies, policies I disagreed with to
only claiming to be about those policies while
not actually doing a thing about it.
And we saw more and more that the Republican
Party became obsessed with grievances.
The so-called war on Christmas.
They were fighting, fighting, non-existent
censorship, fighting nonexistent oppression
by gay people at what they called the gay
lobby rather than of LGBTQ folks, that type
of thing.
And then Trump ran on policy, terrible policy,
but he ran on it and then just didn't do it.
When he became president of the United States,
he ran on building a wall.
He didn't build it.
He ran on replacing Obamacare with a beautiful
new health care plan.
Plan never existed.
I think we're still two weeks away from Trump
unveiling it, even though he's out of office.
He ran on paying off the debt in one term.
He did the opposite.
And over the presidency of Donald Trump, the
Republican Party went from being about these
bad policy ideas to being about the news.
This fake, you can only trust us.
Everybody else is lying to you.
Democrats are censoring you and social media
censoring you.
And they're being unfair to Trump.
They're canceling Thanksgiving.
They're canceling Christmas.
They're canceling the Constitution.
They're canceling, you know, covid guidelines
violate the Constitution.
And so what we have left today is a Trump
in Republican Party that is about nothing
other than performative outrage.
What policy is Marjorie Taylor Greene about?
Nothing.
She barely even pretends to be about policy
because she knows nothing about policy and
it's essentially a grievance campaign.
What policy is Madison Cawthorn about?
Nothing.
And in fact, we've gotten reports from inside
his staff that he is running a communications
platform rather than a policy platform.
We know we could tell it's all about being
outraged at the left for things that don't
even exist.
And right wing media has jumped on the train,
probably because it's profitable for them.
I'm going to play a clip now that is the epitome
of this.
Fox News invited a Minnesota Republican state
senator named Julia Coleman on.
Why did they do that?
Because she's furious.
And Fox News is outraged that.
Minnesota educational standards don't rail
against socialism enough, and that's the reason
that she's outraged.
Take a look.
Standards have a stated purpose, more like
that of the 16 19 project than that of maintaining
freedom.
Well, that it's all part of an evolution that
went from the civics department to social
studies.
Here's here's a reality.
We actually reached out to the Minnesota Department
of Education for a statement.
Here's a portion of what they said.
They said, The benchmarks listed in this first
draft are simply examples of what could be
included under each standard historical US
events like World War Two and the Holocaust
are being taught in Minnesota schools.
We welcome Senator Coleman's feedback as we
as well as the feedback of every American.
So based on what you've revealed, do you feel
like they're fairly including portions of,
say, World War Two?
And would they exclude them if no one spoke
up about it?
If you didn't expose this, what would they
get away with?
Well, quite frankly, this is not exactly true
what they're saying, because five thousand
parents in Minnesota reached out to the review
board stating their concerns and they were
brushed off in a recent meeting.
Now, if you're having trouble understanding
what she's so mad about and what Fox host
Pete Hegseth is so mad about, it's because
it's all a performative farce.
This is what the Republican Party in the immediate
post Trump era is about nothing, outrage,
porn based on nothing.
Now, the question becomes and it's a it's
an important question for the Republican Party
to answer, how long can the Republican Party
survive on the platform of baseless outrage?
For a while it will work because you're getting
people outraged.
But if they continue to be about imaginary
censorship while voting against the covid
relief bill that Joe Biden and Democrats get
done and it gets money to people and voters
know it, what is this outrage, performative
nonsense do for them in the twenty two midterms?
I don't know the answer and it remains to
be seen, but it could be very, very bad.
And we'll talk about it a little bit more
later in the context of this third party that
Donald Trump is looking at and which 64 percent
of Republicans, if you can believe it, would
be open to joining and abandoning the Republican
Party.
We'll talk about that later.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,